was kann die Ukraine denn noch
ausrichten wenn ihn diese Unterstützung
aktuell fehlt sowohl in den USA als auch
in der EU hängen diese Hilfen ja aktuell
ähm ja also man man muss eines ganz klar
sagen und vielleicht habe ich das in der
Vergangenheit zu wenig deutlich gesagt
also allen meinen Einschätzungen und
Berechnungen liegt natürlich eine
wesentliche Annahme zugrunde nämlich
dass die westlichen Waffenlieferungen
weitergehen also wenn die aufhören hört
die Ukraine auf das muss man mal ganz
klar sagen und sie haben jetzt viel
gesprochen äh über die Kosten der
Unterstützung der Ukraine aber man muss
die Kosten auch relativ sehen nämlich zu
dem Szenario dass Russland tatsächlich
gewinnt also sich durchsetzt das heißt
das Ende der Ukraine als Staat die
großflächige Besetzung
und dann überlegen Sie mal was das für
Kosten verursacht dann haben wir ich
weiß nicht wie viel Flüchtlinge aber
sagen wir mal 15 bis 20 Millionen sie
können sich vorstellen wo die hinkommen
dann haben wir ein Russland das an der
polnischen Grenze steht und
überlegen Sie mal was das für Kosten
dann verursacht nicht nur für Europa
sondern auch für die Amerikaner also
dann haben wir wirklich wieder Kalten
Krieg und zwar massiv und ich denke
schon wenn man das so mal ansieht dann
bekommt der Westen seine Sicherheit
eigentlich zu einem sehr sehr günstigen
Preis wenn sie mal vergleichen was in
die Ukraine bisher hineingeschoben wurde
also sprich Waffensysteme die das Ende
ihrer Lebensdauer erreicht haben das
gilt z.B für die Leo paner das gilt für
die abamsp das gilt für das gilt für
glsdb was jetzt kommt im im Januar also
es ja nicht so dass das modernes
Hightech wäre sondern das sind Arsenale
die man in den 90er Jahren den Nuller
Jahren gebaut hat und wo man sagt okay
eigentlich sind die ausgemustert aber da
kann man sie noch verwenden
so und selbst mit diesem relativ kleinen
und passiven Ansatz erreicht man schon
in der Ukraine große operative Wirkung
das liegt nicht nur an den ukrainischen
Streitkräften es liegt vor allem daran
dass die Russen eben die gleichen Fehler
immer wieder machen unfähig sind zum
Gefecht der verbundenen Waffen jetzt
überlegen Sie sich mal was möglich wäre
wenn man die Ukraine wirklich massiv
ausstatten würde mit Artillerie mit
luftkampfmitteln und so weiter das war
genau das Problem des Sommer 22 ähm man
hat Russland die Zeit gegeben um
Grabensysteme und Minenfelder
zu bauen einzurichten und damit hat man
de facto den Krieg verlängert so jetzt
ist halt die Frage was was will man
haben also will man eine freie und
unabhängige Ukraine weil sonst macht es
ja auch keinen Sinn EU
Beitrittsverhandlungen zu liefern dann
muss es eine Ukraine sein die sich
militärisch in diesem Krieg gegen
Russland bewährt denn sonst geht sie als
Staat unter und das bedeutet äh man muss
darauf hinarbeiten dass die Ukraine
wiederhergestellt wird in ihren Grenzen
von 1991 oder man sagt tja Ukraine ja
ist mir eigentlich egal dann wird dieser
Krieg zu Gunsten Russlands ausgehen dann
steht Russland an der polnischen Grenze
und dann kann man ganz Westeuropa wieder
aufrüsten und dann können sich die
Amerikaner aber auf eine
Haushaltsdebatte gefasst machen weil was
dann an Milliarden Beträgen da so
rauskommt das will ich lieber gar nicht
wissen und dann ist übrigens auch
Schluss mit Pivot to Asia ne weil das
muss man ja nebenher auch noch
finanzieren so also in in dem
Zusammenhang muss man das ganze mal
sehen ähm was sind die Kosten in
Verhältnis zu welchem operativen
Ergebnis und vielleicht habe ich das in
der Vergangenheit noch nicht deutlich
genug gesagt also auch hier wieder
großland meine russentrolle aber
Russland ist der Feind falls Sie das
noch nicht gemerkt haben Russland ist äh
das Gegenmodell zu unserer westlich
freiheitlichen Ordnung und es setzt
diese gerade in der Ukraine unter Druck
nach dem Motto schauen wir mal wie wie
stark wir drauf hauen müssen
die die feigendemokraten im Westen die
werden schon irgendwann aufgeben und
dann errichten wir wieder unsere
sogenannte Einflusssphäre dann geht's
wieder zurück ins Jahr
1987 so
das sind die hässlichen Realitäten denen
sich der Westen gegenüber steht und ich
glaube den Leuten ist noch nicht bewusst
in was für einer Tragweite das
stattfindet und in in was für einer
welthistorischen Stunde wir uns im
Moment befinden was mich immer so so
fasziniert ist dass die Medien den Krieg
so ein Biss bisschen auffassen als eine
Soap Opera ja also wenn wenn die Ukraine
mal wieder Erfolge erzielt dann herrscht
Euphorie und wenn sie mal irgendwo
wieder zwei baumlinien verliert dann
herrscht Panik und um Gottes Willen
Russland gewinnt ich würde doch wirklich
nahleen das ganze von von dieser
historischen Perspektive auszubreiten
warum es hier wirklich geht nämlich
nicht irgendwelche Geländegewinne oder
nicht irgendwelche
Artillerie Statistiken ähm sondern es
ist eine fundamentale ideologische
Auseinandersetzung welchem System Europa
künftig angehört und wenn sie wirklich
indifferent sind gegen der gegenüber der
Ukraine dann ist das implizit eine
Unterstützung der russischen Position
das
ist sicher eine ideologische
Auseinandersetzung trotzdem muss man ja
sagen dass diese Debatte gerade anders
geführt wird als noch vor einem Jahr ich
meine jetzt war selenski am Dienstag in
Washington und wurde dann nicht mehr mit
Standing Ovations begrüßt und das fragen
sich auch viele User hier gerade im Chat
hier fragt jemand Biden sagte wir
versprechen die die Ukraine so lange mit
Waffen zu beliefern wie wir können was
erwartet die Ukraine wenn dieser Fall
eintritt ich denke hier der Fall dass
die USA nicht mehr kann und wer
kompensiert den Ausfall wäre so eine
Kompensation überhaupt
möglich ja sie kennen ja den Spruch ich
glaube er ist von Churchill die
Amerikaner tun am Ende immer das
richtige aber erst nachdem Sie alle
falschen Optionen durchprobiert haben
und so ein bisschen erscheint mir gerade
auch die die US Innenpolitik also gut
die us Innenpolitik ist immer ist immer
messy und und chaotisch ja das ist schon
klar aber wie gesagt äh das was ich
vorhin gesagt habe die diese Rechnung
gilt natürlich primär für die USA und
die USA müssen sich natürlich schon
überlegen was das heißt ne also spare
ich jetzt ein paar Millionen dadurch
dass ich dass ich 30 Jahre alte
Waffensysteme nicht liefere ähm und und
nehme ich dafür
nehme ich dafür in in Kauf dass Russland
sich vorschiebt an die polnische Grenze
also die die Diskussion die ist absurd
und die braucht man gar nicht führen
ähmo worum es natürlich geht ist ist die
übliche innenpolitische
Auseinandersetzung dass dass man eben
versucht äh möglichst viele politische
Zugeständnisse zu erpressen von Seiten
der Gegenpartei dafür dass dann die
Regierungspartei irgendwelche Projekte
durchsetzen kann also ich denke das ist
das übliche Chaos der Innenpolitik aber
was man auch sehen muss ist es gibt eine
nahtlose Außenpolitik der
US-Administration
gegenüber der Ukraine ähm und man man
sagt ja immer um Gottes Willen wenn
Trump wieder Präsident wird un so weiter
beliebte angsterzählung in den Medien
aber man muss auch eins dananz sagen es
war die Trump Administration die nach
Minsk i die Ukraine begonnen hat
aufzurüsten also sie auszustatten mit
mit javelins und andlas ihr
Militärberater geschickt hat ihre
geholfen hat ihre Armee zu reformieren
in Kampftaktiken beigebracht hat und so
weiter alles unter der Trump
Administration also man man darf nicht
so den Fehler machen die die politischen
Figuren also die Präsidenten der USA und
und die politischen Kämpfe im Senat oder
im prä tantenhaus ähm zu verwechseln ähm
mit den eigentlichen geostrategischen
Interessen der freien Welt und
m es es gibt ja solche die Sagen in der
Ukraine findet ein Stellvertreterkrieg
statt meistens sind das Russen Trolle
oder oder russische Propaganda ähm aber
das das ist nicht so sondern hier wird
ein souveräner Staat überfallen von
einem Staat der das genau gegenteilige
Modell äh einer freien Weltordnung
vertritt äh ein Staat der sich nicht
kümmert um das Völkerrecht nicht kümmert
um die souveräne Gleichheit der Nationen
nicht kümmert um das westfähische
Prinzip sondern einfach regiert nach dem
Motto das sogenannte Recht des Stärkeren
das hat in der Welt zu herrschen so und
wenn die Amerikaner sich noch halbwegs
in den Spiegel schauen möchten nach
diesem Krieg dann müssen Sie jetzt das
betonen was sie immer betonen the
Constitution also sprich die die
amerikanische Verfassung ist ja nicht
nur ein innenpolitisches Werk sondern
sie ist auch ein ideologisches Werk in
dem Sinne dass sie sagt ähm prinzipiell
gilt hier
äh die rule of law also die Bindung der
Macht an das Recht und wenn man diesen
Gedanken überträgt auf die
internationale Ordnung ähm dann können
die Amerikaner äh so etwas nicht
tolerieren vielleicht ist Westeuropa
schon zu dekadent geworden und und
kümmert sich um sowas nicht mehr aber
wie gesagt wenn wenn Sie das Zulassen
ähm dann würden sie damit aktiv einen
Hegemon schaffen auf der eurasischen
Landmasse der den Großteil der
Ressourcen und der Menschen kontrolliert
oder zumindest unter Druck setzen kann
das wäre die größtmögliche Bedrohung
Westeuropas und wenn das so wäre dann
wird's wirklich teuer für die Amerikaner
wir haben dazu auch eine Frage aus der
Community Herr K würden sie die Meinung
teilen Russland setzt alles ein um
Geländegewinne zu erzielen dann nächstes
Jahr Wahlen anstehen und Putin
erfolgebraucht
ähm also den bei dem ersten Teil der
Aussage würde ich zustimmen ja Russland
setzt massiv Reserven ein um irgendwo
einen operativen Durchbruch zu erzielen
das stimmt schon also sie wie in wie ich
erklärt habe sie werfen massiv
Ressourcen rein bisher scheitern sie
aber mit dem mit dem Vormarsch also es
gibt nicht irgendwo einen größeren
operativen Durchbruch der zweite Teil
also die der also die Worte Wahlen und
Russland in einem Satz zu nennen das ist
heute schon ziemlich sportlich also die
die sogenannten Wahlen sind ungefähr so
demokratisch und und gleich und geheim
wie in der
Sowjetunion nein also das ist völlig
egal wie dieses Ergebnis ausgeht oder
der steht sowieso schon fest also mit
den Wahlen hat es hat es sicher nichts
zu tun wenn wir gerade schon mal bei der
russischen Seite sind lassen sie uns mal
auf dieses russische Video
gucken genau wir sehen hier wie Panzer
an die Front verlagert werden und das
ist altes Gerät das sind T64 Panzer die
angeblich schon längst verschrottet sein
sollten was sagt uns das denn über den
Zustand des russischen Geräts Herr Kolb
na das sagt uns zwei Dinge das das eine
ist ja das was ich seit März diesen
Jahres gesagt habe
die einsatzfähige Reserve also spricht
das was Russland vor dem Krieg an an
einsatzfähigen modernen Systemen hatte
also das heißt t72 und alles was nach
dem t72 gekommen ist also T80 t80s T90
und so weiter und die Varianten des T90
die neigen sich langsam dem Ende zu und
jetzt müssten sie eigentlich in ihre
Rüstungsindustrie hineingehen und
nachproduzieren bzw die eingelagerten
Bestände von T22 und neueren Systemen
aktivieren dafür haben sie aber nicht
die Kapazität also was machen Sie sie
werfen ältere Systeme an die Front also
wie z.B hier den T64 wir haben auch
schon bestätigte Bilder von t62 und
sogar schon von einem T55 an der Front
gesehen ich nenne das ja immer
scherzhaft Eskalation nach unten es gibt
ja diejenigen die sagen russland habe
die eskalationsdomin und ich sag dann
immer ja ja nur auf der technologiekurve
geht's halt dann leider nach unten ne
also wenn ich solche Videos sehe dann
dann interpretiere ich das eigentlich
als Bestätigung dieses Effekts
die die einsatzfähigen modernen Systemen
sind langsam bald abgeschossen so und
solange sie nicht die industrielle
Kapazität haben um massiv neue moderne
Systeme nachzuschieben was machen Sie
sie greifen ins Lager und schieben ihre
Altbestände nach also sprich was von den
sowjetischen Beständen noch
übrig ist und jetzt ist halt die große
Frage wie groß sind noch diese diese
Altbestände mal 60 000 ernähnt
Kampfpanzer von dem Niveau sind wir
längst weg aber was da noch in in
irgendwelchen sibirischen Depots
rumsteht das ist halt letztlich
Spekulation genau das ist Spekulation
und das ist Altgerät aber sagt das nicht
auch dass die russische Armee hat mehr
hat als von vielen Experten ursprünglich
erwartet
wurde ja das hängt davon ab was Sie mit
mehr meinen ne ich sage ja immer Anzahl
ist nicht gleich Einheitswert also nur
weil sie weil sie 1000 Stück irgendeines
Altsystems haben heißt es noch lange
nicht dass es operative Wirkung erzielt
ja sondern das ist dann die Frage wie
setzen Sie das Ganze ein äh in in
welchem Szenario hat es eine Chance
gegen gegnerische Systeme wenn die
Russen ihre Panzer weiterhin so
verheizen äh wie sie es bisher getan
haben mache ich mir eigentlich keine
Sorgen ähm wenn Sie diese Panzer direkt
gegen Leo 2 oder auch nur Leo 1
einsetzen würden dann wäre das ein Kampf
auf sehr ungleichem technologieniveau
was man machen kann ist man man kann die
Panzer als artillerieersatz nehmen also
man kann sie eingraben im Boden und dann
wie eine artilleriekanone verwenden aber
das ist eigentlich nicht die Idee eines
Panzers die Idee des Panzers ist
Beweglichkeit und Vorstoß nach vorne
also spricht das das ist eigentlich das
warum ich sage Putin hat ein
strukturelles Problem von dem man nicht
von dem man nicht wegkommt er kann
Reserven nachschieben ja klar er kann
weiter Stück an die Front werfen aber
das heißt nicht dass er damit
Einsatzwert erzielt und das sehen sie
eben in auf die jifka ne sie opfern
Material hin aber sie haben nicht nicht
wirklich irgendeinen Gegenwert dafür und
das kann er machen äh bis alle Lager
leer sind ich ich ermutige ihn sogar das
zu tun es ist ein großer Beitrag zur
Abrüstung Eurasiens ein großer Beitrag
zur europäischen
Sicherung sie sprechen jetzt von einer
Eskalation nach unten bei russischem
Gerät und sagen ja dass die Ukraine wenn
sie etwas nachbekommt Modernes
westliches Gerät nachbekommt jetzt ist
es ja aber auch so dass in der Ukraine
lang nicht alles ankommt was vom Westen
versprochen wird bzw nur sehr Zeit
verzögert sind sie damit nicht auch ein
Stück weit zu
unkritisch na das würde ich nicht sagen
es es hängt davon ab was Sie für ein
Waffensystem anschauen also es stimmt
dass es Verzögerungen gibt die sind
teils politischer Natur teils
technischer Natur also jetzt z.B bei
glsdb also ground Launch small diameter
bombs das sind diese
diese
raketenartillerie Dinger mit 150 km
Reichweite die sie aus den heimarystemen
abschliießen die sollten eigentlich im
Oktober kommen kommen jetzt erst im
Januar
vermutlich wegen Sicherheitsbedenken
weil man erstmal guckt gucken will dass
die Raketenmotoren überhaupt verlässlich
sind weil das sind 30 Jahre alte Systeme
man hat zwar viel davon 17 000 aber
trotzdem safety first oder das ist ein
Grund
andere Dinge die da hat man die Lage
voll man will sie aber nicht liefern aus
aus irgendwelchen politischen Erwägungen
da muss ich sagen ja ist ist nicht meine
Sache die Politik zu kritisieren
militärisch wären die Bestände da wenn
die Politiker das nicht wollen dann
sollten Sie die Fragen und nicht mich
ähm und bei bei manchen Systemen hat es
hat es logistische Gründe ähm ist
einfach wenn also es gibt ein eine
Zeitverzögerung zwischen wann ist ein
System zugesagt und wann ist es operativ
einsatzfähig ne also z.B sehen Sie bei
den kampflugzeugen die kamplugzeuge sind
zugesagt sie sind auch da in Rumänien
die Piloten trainieren damit aber sie
haben einfach eine gewisse
Ausbildungszeit bis diese Dinge dann
operative Wirkung
entfallen entfalten das werden wir dann
ab dem frühahr sehen also ich bchte mal
März April werden die F16 dann
einsatzfähig sein aber das das ist ist
kein Widerspruch sondern das ist halt
der der Masse und der Kompliziertheit
militärischer Logistik geschuldet ich
habe hier noch eine Frage aus der
Community hier schreibt jemand auf
Youtube überall rücken die Russen vor
und gewinnen an Boden ich verstehe das
nicht ich dachte die Ukraine wird den
Krieg gewinnen aber die Russen drehen
jetzt erst richtig auf warum habt ihr
euch so
geirrt also ja
da frage ich mich was was bezeichnen sie
mit dem Wort aufdrehen ja ich glaube da
sind sie so ein bisschen Opfer der
russischen Propaganda geworden oder
haben haben zu viel telegram Videos
geguckt es es ist schon so dass dass die
russischen milblogger sehr sehr laut und
freudig dann verkünden wenn man wieder
eine eine treeline also so eine
baumlinie vorgerückt ist es stimmt schon
dass es im Moment eine Bewegung gibt an
verschiedenen Sektoren der Front wo
Russland leichte Geländegewinne erzielt
nur müssen sie das halt im Verhältnis
sehen erstens zuur abnutzungsrate
die enorm ist sowohl bei Personal wie
auch bei Material und zweitens zum
operattiv en Wert dieses vorrückens ja
also nur dadurch dass sie irgendwelche
Geländestreifen einnehmen oder zwei
baumlinien vorrücken haben Sie noch
keinen operativen Wert erzielt es kommt
also das sage ich immer wieder es kommt
in diesem Krieg nicht so sehr auf die
mechanische Komponente an also wer hält
im Moment wie viel Gelände sondern es
kommt darauf an wer die enorme Abnutzung
dieses Krieges länger durchhält und wer
die Logistik besser organisieren kann
das das sage ich auch immer wieder wenn
wenn Militärs sagen ja Pfeilchen rot
Pfeilchen blau und Pfeilchen rot rückt
vor ähm es geht hier nicht nur um
filchen rot versus blau sondern dieser
Krieg hat eine technische und
logistische Komponente äh die man nicht
ignorieren
darf und wir haben noch eine letzte
Frage aus der Community ähm hier fragt
jemand wie soll das demokratische Europa
gegen die Kriegswirtschaft Putins
bestehen Produktionskapazitäten sind
doch bei den Russen deutlich größer ah
ja ja klar deswegen gehen sie auch nach
Nordkorea und holen von dort die
Artilleriemunition ne und deswegen äh
beziehen sie ihre drohen aus dem Iran
mhm ja ist total glaubwürdig das
Argument also wissen Sie wenn Sie sich
wirklich mal mit der russischen
Rüstungsindustrie beschäftigen dann
haben sie vor allem zwei Probleme
erstens Korruption zweitens
systematisches fälschen der Zahlen nach
oben war schon in der Sowjetunion so hat
sich nichts
geändert ich glaube nicht dass Russland
die produktivkapazität hat um erstens
massiv aufzurüsten und zweitens genügend
Nachschub an modernen Systemen an die
Front zu liefern wenn Sie das könnten
hätten sie es längst getan Putin
inszeniert sich natürlich sehr gut wenn
er z sagt künftig 6% des Staatsbudgets
ähm in die Rüstungsindustrie ich muss
dann immer lachen und sagen ja ja von
den 6% gehen mindestens 50% durch
Korruption verloren aber so bet glauben
wir es ihm mal
ähm nur dadurch dass sie dass sie
irgendwelche Gelder sprechen oder
irgendwelche propagand Videos in in
Omsk oder sonst wo
[Musik]
drehen in diesen panzerwerken heißt es
noch lange nicht dass dadurch operative
Wirkung herauskommt es es zeigt aber wie
wirksam die russische Propaganda in
Europa ist und wie wie sehr sie immer
noch von vielen Menschen geglaubt wird
und eine abschließende Frage habe ich
noch ich glaube es ist ziemlich klar
geworden in den letzten 40 45 Minuten
dass sie die Ukraine klar im Vorteil
sehen sie sagen auch Putin bleiben noch
rund 100 Tage wie kommen Sie denn auf
diese sehr klar formulierte
Zahl ja das das ist die Extrapolation
der abnutzungsrate also ich ich habe ja
immer mich bezogen auf die
auf die Schätzung des iiss und des
schwedischen foi
die die einsatzfähige Reserve russ vor
dem Krieg abgeschätzt haben und wenn sie
den Durchschnitt bilden dann kommen Sie
auf eine Zahl von etwa 2900 laut der
orix Liste sind wir bei jetzt etwa 2450
wenn Sie also die
die durchschnittliche Verlustquote der
Russen die nach wie vor liegt bei fünf
Panzern pro Tag ähm und hochrechnen oder
dann dann würden Sie sagen okay
bis zu dem bis zu der einsatzfähigen
Reserve die damals berechnet worden ist
fehlen noch 500 geteilt durch fünf
Verlustrate pro Tag haben sie noch
ungefähr 100 Tage das heißt jetzt
Vorsicht nicht dass dass die Trolle mich
wieder hier missverstehen und und dann
wieder hetzartikelchen schreiben das
heißt nicht dass der Krieg in 100 Tagen
vorbei ist ja sondern das heißt dass in
100 Tagen ein entscheidender Punkt der
Abnutzung erreicht ist und ab dann
müssten wir eigentlich das massive
nachschieben von Altem und sehr alte
Material sehen also genau das was sie in
im Video Einspieler gezeigt haben ne und
ab dann
findet eben dieser Krieg zunehmend als
als Differenz von zwei verschiedenen
technologieniveus
ST Herr Kolb danke dass sie meine Fragen
und die Fragen unserer Community
beantwortet haben schönen Abend noch
nach Zürich und bis bald